de la commission
défavorable de la du gouvernement qui
vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
le 727 même voix même
vote 725 même votes et pas
d'adopté merci madame la ministre mes
chers collègues je vous propose
d'enchaîner
est-ce que notre ministre est
là merci l'ordre du jour appelleexamen
des crédits de la mission écologie
développement et mobilité durable du
budget annexe contrôle et exploitation
aérien et du budget spécial financement
des aides aux collectivités pour
l'électrification
rurale la parole est à Madame Christine
Lavarde rapporteur spécial de la
commission des
finances chers collègues vous avez la
parole pour 7
minutes merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
je ne sais pas si je vais avoir assez de
7 minutes pour vous parler préservation
de la biodiversité soutien des
consommateurs
face à la hausse des prix des énergies
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
transition du parc automobile
vulnérabilité face aux événements
climatiques exceptionnel soutien au
développement des énergies et de la
chaleur renouvelable alors heureusement
les nombreux amendements qui ont été
déposés me permettront d'aborder les
différents sujets au cours de la journée
alors je voudrais commencer par vous
parler de la Stratégie nationale pour la
biodiversité pour 2030 qui a été
présentée la semaine dernière alors la
presse est largement fait écho du
milliard d'euros mis sur la table alors
j'ai cherché un petit peu parce que ce
milliard d'euros ne m'avait pas frappé
l'esprit en lisant la documentation
budgétaire alors heureusement dans le
dans le dossier de presse j'ai réussi à
trouver 264 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sur le programme 113 je
suis au regret de vous dire qu'il s'agit
en fait simplement d'un transfert des
crédits du programme 380 sur le
programme 113 alors l'année dernière il
fallait certainement gonfler l'enveloppe
budgétaire du programme fond vert cette
année avec beaucoup justesse on met
l'ensemble des crédits liés à la
biodiversité sur le programme 1130 ce
dont je ne peux que me réjouir 400
millions d'euros qui sont financés sur
le programme 380 au titre de la
renaturation et du recyclage des friches
là encore dans un dossier de presse j'ai
trouvé une information qui n'était pas
disponible dans la documentation
budgétaire et ben oui parce que le fond
vert c'est une litanie d'actions qui
peuvent être financé sans qu'il n'y soit
jamais assortie les moyens financiers
mis en place alors je sais monsieur le
ministre vous AZ m'expliquer que c'est
la philosophie du fond vert c'est un
outil flexible à la main des préfets
pour répondre aux demandes des
collectivités locales je suis désolée
j'ai mené un certain nombre d'audition
et la réalité ne se conforte pas
toujours avec la théorie c'est la raison
pour laquelle le Sénat a voté une
affectation de titicpe pour permettre
aux EPCI et aux régions de financer la
mise en œuvre de leur pcaet et enfin le
milliard se termine par 475 millions
d'euros au titre de la préservation du
milieu aquatique par les agences de
l'eau et alors là encore j'ai dû
chercher et ben en fait il s'agit du
plan haut du 30 mars dernier CES 475
millions d'euros seront relevés selon
seront financés en de temps avec le
relèvement du plafond des agences de
l'eau alors ce plan haut 53 mesures
majoritairement pour la sobriété la
préservation de la ressource et la
gouvernance malheureusement pas beaucoup
pour ce qui concerne vraiment la
biodiversité puisque j'ai trouvé que 10
mesures qui qui relèvent de l'objectif
préserver la qualité de l'eau et
restaurer les écosystèmes sains et
fonctionnels et j'en ai trouvé seulement
trois qui concernent le grand cycle de
dont une financée par le fond vert c'est
fantastique dans cette mission tout est
circulaire alors en fait si je le dis
plus autrement malheureusement les
crédits verts n'augmentent pas beaucoup
et ce ministère mais je pense que c'est
bien de le dire c'est celui de
l'économie circulaire et de la sobriété
mais c'est un bon exemple pour
l'ensemble des autres ministères quand
on a 150 milliards de déficit et même
parfois les crédits sont gonflés
artificiellement un seul exemple le fond
vert on crée une nouvelle sansaction
sous-action dotée de 100 millions
d'euros qui s'appelle territoire
d'industrie mais cette sous-action elle
a vocation à l'industrialisation des
territoires pourquoi n'est-elle pas
portée par la Mission économie et même
les crédits sont diminués pendant la
navette on a supprimé 400 millions
d'euros d'AE au programme 174 pour les
basculer sur le programme 175 pour
financer un fond de rénovation à
destinateur des bailleurs sociaux alors
j'ai envie de vous dire que c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle pour l'efficacité de
l'argent public parce que la partie de
ma prime renve qui est porté par le
programme 135 elle finance des
rénovations globales et performantes
donc des rénovations qui ont un
véritable impact sur la baisse de la
consommation et pour les crédits qui
sont rattachés à la mission écologie
ceux du 174 malheureusement il s'agit
uniquement d'une décarbonation du
chauffage c'est un monogeste avec un
effet et une
plusvalueironnementale beaucoup plus
faible si c'est alors je vais quand même
vous donner quelques points de
satisfaction le Sénat sait être entendu
dans ce budget un exemple les critères
d'attribution du bonus qui seront mis en
œuvre en 2024 qui permettent de tenir en
fin compte du bilan carbone et du sur
l'ensemble du cycle du vie du véhicule
mais c'est vraiment dommage du coup que
les crédits du bonus et de la prime à la
conversion soi plus faible en 2024 que
l'exécution 2023
ensuite la nouvelle sous-action soutien
aux autorités organisatrices de la
mobilité en milieu rural et ben c'est
directement la recommandation numéro 5
du rapport de mes collègues Stéphane
satarel et Hervé Moré et malheureusement
quand vous n'avez pas su entendre le
Sénat il a avait raison je pense ici à
la décision du Conseil d'État du 23
janvier 2023 qui a annulé l'arrêté pris
pour la mise en œuvre la révision des
contrats photovoltaïques de 2006 à 2011
dans sa sagesse le Sénat avait supprimé
la mesure le gouvernement s'est obstiné
conclusion au lieu de 3 milliards
d'économie on a eu que des coûts échoués
alors c'est pourquoi je vous invite à
suivre le Sénat quand dans la journée
nous vous proposerons de supprimer les
alinéas de l'article 52 qui vise à
réviser le complément prix de la reine
et le Sénat sait aussi vous entendre en
2023 monsieur le ministre Béchu vous
nous invitiez au cours de la discussion
à réformer la fiscalité pour tenir
compte du fait qu'un véhicule plus lourd
émet plus de partic de pollution par
l'abrasion des freins et ben c'est ce
que nous avons fait à l'article 14 nous
avons intégré les véhicules lourds dans
le malus poid madame la ministre panière
unachier hier vous avez indiqué que le
bouclier tarifaire va disparaître
courant 2024 là aussi le Sénat a
anticipé vos propos puisque à l'article
11 nous avons supprimé et nous avons
remis les assis sur l'électricité alors
niveau d'avant-crise et madame la
ministre vous nous faites un faux procès
quand vous nous dites que les tarifs
vont augmenter de 20 % avec cette mesure
nous avons fait des calculs nous
n'arrivons pas au même chiffre que vous
ou alors les hypothèses qu'on nous a
présenté sont fausses et en et c'est et
c'est le en même temps de la majorité
sénatoriale c'est-à-dire que c'est un
dispositif une mesure de responsabilité
nous disons qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
de venir aider tous les ménages et c'est
aussi une mesure d'équité puisqueavec
notre dispositif et l'amendement de
crédit qui sera porté dans la journée
nous allons soutenir davantage les
ménages les moins favorisés que les
ménages les plus aisés et enfin je
voudrais terminer sur le fond vert sur
le fond climat territorial que le Sénat
va très certainement voter cet
après-midi il va vous permettre monsieur
le ministre de mettre en œuvre la fiche
de presse qui a été diffusée lors du
congrès des maires car j'ai lu dans
cette fiche les élus locaux connaissent
par parfaitement les défis
environnementaux auxquels ils sont
confrontés et ben avec ce fond climat
territorial on va leur permettre de leur
donner les moyens pour faire selon leur
calendrier et leurs priorités car je
pense que tous ensemble ici nous
partageons qu'il faut bâtir une écologie
ancrée dans le quotidien des Français
très bien merci la parole est à Madame
marieaire CARG madame la
rapporteur 7 minutes merci monsieur le
Président Madame Monsieur ministre mes
mes chers collègues en préembule je me
permets de vous présenter toutes les
excuses de mon corrapporteur Hervé Moret
mes premiers mots s'adresseront au
ministrees pour leur dire que nous
attendons d'eux au cours de ce débat un
engagement ferme sur une date précise
concernant la révision de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités par le
Parlement elle aurait dû intervenir
depuis juin dernier on le sait tous il
faut décarboner et développer les
transports collectifs ça coûte très cher
et nous sommes sous contrainte
financière très sérieuse il est donc
impératif que le Parlement débatte
rapidement d'un volume d'investissement
et d'une programmation pour les années
qui viennent l'engagement de la première
ministre de reprendre le scénario
central du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures soit 26 milliards d'ici
2027 et certes louable mais il ne serait
s'y
substituer nous obervons avec
satisfaction que pour 2024 le budget de
la fit France prend en compte ces enjeux
de décarbonation ses ressources
devraient augmenter de 800 millions et
ses dépenses pourraient atteindre 4,6
milliards permettez-moi cependant de
mettre l'accent sur plusieurs points qui
nous
interpellent le premier qui va payer les
besoins de régénération et de
modernisation du réseau ferroviaire nous
avons bien entendu que la première
ministre ser a repris à son compte les
propositions formulées dès mars 2022 par
Hervé Morel Hervé Moret et Stéphane
sotarel dans leur rapport d'information
sur la situation financière de la SNCF
qui avait elle-même été reprise ensuite
par le COI la première ministre a en
effet annoncé que d'ici 2027 les
dépenses de régénération et de
modernisation du réseau augmenteront de
1,5 milliard d'euros par an mais les
zones d'ombre sont nombreuses pour 2024
la hausse significative des crédits du
programme 203 s'explique principalement
par l'augmentation de la contribution de
SNCF voyageurs nous redoutons mais vous
le démentirez sans doute madame et
messieur le ministre que l'État entende
que la SNCF finance seul ses
investissements si lourds pour les
années qui
viennent faire payer la SNCF seule
présenterait plus plusieurs risques à
supposer d'ailleurs que la SNCF puisse
le supporter 1 cela pèserait sur les
investissement de SNCF voyageur pour
développer l'offre on ne le souhaite pas
de cela alimenterait l'inflation des
prix des billets on ne le souhaite pas
plus 3 ce serait antinomique avec le
contexte d'ouverture à la concurrence
SNCF voyageur se trouverait en effet
lesté d'un lourd handicap face à ses
concurrents
deè point de vigilance de la commission
c'est la spirale de dégradation dans
laquelle est engagé le réseau routier
national non concédé un audit de 2018
chiffrait à au moins 1 milliard d'euros
d'investissement annuel soit
l'équivalent de 1,2 milli 1,2 milliards
d'euros
actuels l'équivalent des crédits
nécessair pour enrayer cette dégradation
or pour 2024 les crédits devraient tout
juste atteindre 1 milliard ce qui est
trop
juste trème point de vigilance et de
préoccupation de notre commission en
juillet dernier notre mission
d'information sur les AOM adressé un
constat très précis du besoin de
financement des mobilité du quotidien
vous en avez tenu compte pour IDFM qui
se trouve dans une situation très
particulière grâce au protocole de
financement conclu avec la région et qui
trouve sa traduction aux article 27 bis
et 27 TER que nous avons adopté mais
vous continuez d'ignorer les AOM locales
métropolitaine et régional c'est
pourquoi nous avons fait adopter un
amendement visant à leur affecter une
nouvelle ressource et une ressource
pérenne dès 2024 une fraction des 250
millions d'euros du produit des mises
enchè mises aux enchères des quotas
carbone par comparaison avec une
augmentation du du vm du versement
mobilité cela permet de ne pas avantager
les seuls AOM bien doté en base fiscale
et d'apporter enfin une solution à la
mobilité en zone rurale la grande
oubliée du financement des transports du
quotidien 4è point de vigilance et de
préoccupation le fret la Commission
européenne a lancé une enquête sur les
aides publiques à la société Fret
SNCF pour éviter le scénario catastrophe
d'un possible rembours de 5 milliards
d'euros plus une amendee le gouvernement
a proposé un plan de discontinuité qui
est tout de même assez douloureux nous
souhaitons Madame et Monsieur le
Ministre partager avec vous notre vive
préoccupation devant l'approche qui est
celle de la Commission européenne elle
nous paraît caricaturale et elle nous
paraît également contradictoire avec
l'objectif de doublement de la part du
frite ferroviaire en effet d'une part le
secteur du fra ferroviaire est
structurellement déficitaire pas
seulement en France mais plus
généralement en Europe et les seuls
concurrents réels de fret SNCF ce sont
en réalité des opérateurs des sociétés
qui sont elles-mêmes issues d'autres
opérateurs historiques européens c'est
comment dire paradoxal enfin il semble
que le plan de discontinuité conduise
Fret SNCF à abandonner les segments les
plus rentables ou les moins déficitaires
du marché mais vous nous éclairerez sur
ce point madame monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues madame et monsieurs le
ministre je vous renvoie enfin notre
rapport pour l'analyse des crédits du
programme 205 affaires maritimes pêche
et aquaculture et me contenterit
d'observer ici on en parlera plus en
détail lors de l'examen des amendements
que si l'on retraite des phénomènes de
report de crédit et quelques ajustements
et évolution ponctuelles ils seront
relativement stables en 2024 je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
Vincent capo canellaa rapporteur spécial
de la commission des finances pour 7
minutes monsieur le Président madamees
et messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
mes chers collègues je commencerai
d'abord par rendre compte des crédit du
programme 159 expertise information
géographique et météorologie
ce programme regroupe les subventions
pour charge service public du serema de
l'Institut géographique national de
l'information géographie pardon et
forestière hygiène et de météoance après
une décennie de baisse substantielle de
ces moyens météoance connaît un répi qui
est bienvenu depuis l'année dernière et
nous en avions parlé monsieur le
ministre je me souviens dans cet
hémicycle répi bienvenue car comme je
l'avais exposé dans un rapport
d'information il y a 2 ans l'opérateur
Météo France est de plus en en plus
sollicité du fait de la multiplication
des phénomènes extrêmes en 2024 ces
effectifs doivent progresser de 25
emplois c'est notable à l'horizon 2026
Météo France devra par ailleurs investir
dans de nouveaux super calculateurs pour
350 millions d'euros tout n'est pas
réglé mais c'est quand même un pas
l'année dernière dans notre rapport je
vous avais présenter la transformation
en cours au sein de l'hygienne je vous
avais aussi signalé au-delà de cette
stratégie qui était proposée par la
direction générale qui est robuste et
qui mérite d'être conservée je vous ais
aussi signalé quand même un risque euh
de trou d'air en indiant que son modèle
économique était dépendant de grands
programme financés par des
commanditaires publics et souvent par
d'autres ministères d'ailleurs alors qui
parfois se font un peu tirer l'oreille
pour apporter leur obol euh au niveau
des commandes qui peuvaient être les
leurs ou bien pour réactualiser le mon
temp des crédits ce risque de trou d'air
que je présentais est arrivé plus tôt
que je ne pouvais l'imaginer l'hygiène
risquait d'être à cours de trésorerie
dès l'année prochaine et je me réjouis
que nous ayons pu en bonne concertation
avec l'Assemblée le gouvernement et avec
l'aide active du rapporteur général du
Sénat traiter cette question dans le
cadre du projet loi de fa gestion pour
2023 puisqu'à cette occasion j'ai déposé
un amendement qui a été adopté par le
Sénat et qui a permis de verser une
subvention exceptionnelle de 4 million
d'euros à l'opérateur ce versement
permettra à l'ygiène de présenter un
budget à l'équilibre pour le conseil
d'administration qui aura lieu vendredi
ce conseil avait été décalé pour
justement s'assurer qu'un certain nombre
d'autres décisions soit affermie par les
autres ministères et je crois que c'est
le cas je souhaite qu'il y a un conseil
qui permette de continuer sur cette
stratégie qui a été euh excellemment
définie et qu'il faut maintenant mettre
à l'œuvre en se donnant tous les moyens
je viens maintenant sur le le serema si
je puis dire après un passage à ville le
serema a trouvé je crois une vraie
dynamique il y a eu un travail de
remobilisation sur plusieurs années
qu'il faut saluer le nouveau modèle de
quasi régie conjointe état collectivité
que nous avions voté ici même dans la
loi 3DS s mis en place cette année et
les premiers résultats paraissent
encourageants du fait de cette vitalité
retrouvé pour la première fois de son
histoire les effectifs du CEMA devrai
augmenter de 10 emplois en 2024 alors
mis emploi ça ne clot pas forcément
toute la discussion mais malgré tout
c'est aussi un signal dans le bon sens
que je veux saluer j'en viens à présent
au budget annexe contrôle et
exploitation aérien le le
Basa après des années marquées par la
pire crise de son histoire avec une
encoche de trafic très importante
pendant plusieurs années une baisse très
très brutale le transport aérien
retrouve maintenant quelques couleurs le
trafic a presque retrouvé son niveau
d'avant-crise alors il y a des
différences entre le trafic domestique
certaines destinations comme l'Asie par
exemple et puis les difficultés aussi
par les désordres et les guerres dans
différentes secteurs du monde qui
affectent le trafic mais grosso modo on
revient presque au niveau d'avant-crise
en
2024 il y a les conséquences de
rattrapage de de la crise donc le
rattrapage pardon des conséquences de la
crise euh et donc les redevances de
navigation aérienne dépasseront leur
niveau d'avant-crise c'est un élément
majeur puisque vous savez que ce budget
annexe est assis en ressources sur les
redevances le transport aérien s'enorte
mieux on peut s'en réjouir cependant je
ne voudrais pas vous cacher ma
préoccupation s'agissant des
répercussions sur le secteur de la
nouvelle taxe sur l'exploitation des
infrastructures de transport de longue
distance car les aéroports me paraissent
être une victime collatérale de la
volonté de l'État de mettre à
contribution les sociétés d'autoroute
les aéroports sont un peu la libyie dans
cette affaire avec des conséquences
financières qu'il faut regarder j'ai eu
l'occasion détailler à l'occasion de la
discussion de l'article 15 du
PLF mais je voudrais dire que d'une part
cette taxe se traduira par un avantage
concurrentiel pour les compagnies locost
et fragilisera certains aéroports
avantage concurrentiel pour les loost
parce que une partie des loost en tout
cas ne vient pas sur les grands
aéroports la DG GC est en pleine
négociation de son nouveau protocole
social euh et je monsieur le ministre ce
que je veux dire c'est que se pose la
question de la régulation euh tarifaire
et la question du principe de la
modération tarifaire la DGAC est en
pleine négociation son nouveau protocole
social une pratique quelque peu atypique
est sensé se traduire par du donnant
donnant et avec des efforts de
productivité des contrôleurs en échange
de mesures indamnitaires de mon point de
vue jusqu'ici c'est cette pratique n'a
pas fait ses preuves et c'est là un
euphémisme les objectifs en terme de
performance de ce nouveau protocole
semble ambitieux mais je reste dubitatif
le PLF 2024 marque une impulsion
budgétaire supplémentaire en faveur des
investissements de la DSNA j'avais
plaidé sur ce point dans un rapport du
mois de juin dernier et nous sommes
évidemment dans la bonne perspective de
ce plan là il s'agit de mettre en œuvre
une nouvelle impulsion avec la
transition d'un nouveau nouvel outil
d'assistance du contrôle aérien forfight
vers un système qui pourra être
mutualisé avec les partenaires européens
la DSNA
et puis il s'agit aussi de traiter
l'obsolescence des infrastructures qui
avait été un peu perdu de vue mais qui
se rappelle à nous dernier mot sur la
dette du Basa après avoir culminé à 2
milliards 7 d'euros en 2022 elle a
amorcé son repli cette année mais la
décru sera longue monsieur le ministre
pour terminer je voudrais comme je l'ai
fait tout à l'heure en disant qu'il y
avait un souci quand même sur la
régulation aéroportuaire et la
modération tarifaire quand on regarde
les effets de cette nouvelle taxes sur
certains aéroports qui ne pourront pas
la compenser en vertu de la modéraation
tarifaire je vais juste avoir un mot sur
un amendement que j'ai eu le plaisir de
de soumettre au Sénat qui l'a voté
concernant l'incorporation des
carburants durables pour le transport
aérien il me semble que au-delà des
mesures qu'a excellemment annoncé le
président de la République avant salon
du Bourger pour la production de
carburant durable il faut réfléchir à
une incitation et à une régulation sur
les prix car nous avons des prix qui
sont deux fois supérieurs aux États-Unis
par exemple
merci merci chers collègues nous
suspendrons la séance à 13h
je passe la parole à Monsieur Daniel
[Applaudissements]
grem pour 3 minutes chers
collègues monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames et
monessieurs le rapporteurs chers
collègues le PLF pour 2024 constitue un
budget peu protecteur face à des prix
incertains notre commission souscrit à
la revalorisation des crédits liés à la
rénovation énergétique à la mobilité
propre et à la chaleur renouvelable
qu'elle avait appelé de CV l'an passé en
revanche notre commission s'inquiète de
l'extinction des mécanismes
exceptionnels de protection des
consommateurs qui ne dépasse pas 3
milliards en baisse de 90 % un grand
nombre de dispositifs ne sont pas
pleinement reconduit l'exemple de
l'amortisseur et le filet de sécurité
pourélectricité le bouclier individuel
pour le gaz et le chèque fioule et bois
pour les carburants et combustibles or
les prix des énergies demeurent bien
supérieur au niveau d'avant-crise pire
l'État a tendance de capter des recettes
exceptionnelles liées à cette crise le
budget lui permet de doubler l'assise
sur le gaz pour 3,5 milliards mais aussi
de disposer des compléments de prix de
la reine pour 1,6 milliards et des et
des compléments de rénumération de
l'électricité renouvelable pour 1,3
milliards or en juillet dernier notre
commission dans son rapport et la creux
dans sa délibération ont clairement
appelé à ce que les compléments de prix
de laarine bénéficient au consommateur
il nous faut absolument corriger le tir
dans même esprit aucun débat public
n'est conduit sur l'utilisation de la
CSPE sur les énergies renouvelables qui
représente un gain pour l'état de 3
milliards pour ma part je pense
qu'utiliser des gains structurels pour
financer des dépenses con urelle est une
mauvaise pratique budgétaire enfin notre
commission déplore plusieurs angles
morts des crédits ainsi la
rebitalisation des des territoires
touchés par les arrêts de central celle
à charbon et notamment fessonil n'est
pas soutenu de plus la neutralité
technologique n'est pas toujours
appliquée à l'énergie et à l'hydrogène
nucléaire à
l'hydroélectricité au biogaz et au
biocarburant dans ce contexte le Sénat a
adopté il y a quelques jours plusieurs
amendements fiscaux que j'ai présenté à
titre personnel ils ont contribué à
supprimer la hausse de l'ISE sur le gaz
soutenir les électrolyseurs d'hydrogène
et le captage du CO2 et valoriser
l'hydrogène nucléaire au côté de celui
renouvelable de plus pour remédier aux
difficultés que j'ai indiquer notre
commission a adopté C amendements
budgétaires visant 1 à garantir
l'éligibilité des collectivités
territoriales au boucliers tarifaires et
des différents propriétaires à ma prime
Renov augmenté de 350000 € les moyens de
la creux pour contrôler le bouclier
tarifaire de relever de 115 millions les
crédits du chèque énerg énergie de 180
millions ceux du fond chaleur
renouvelable 40 millions ceux du fond de
revitalisation des territoire je forme
le vœux que le PLF pour 2024 et ainsi
infléchi protège les consommateurs et
consolide nos transition et notre
souveraineté énergétique au nom de notre
commission je vous invite donc à adopter
les crédits sous réserve de l'adoption
de ces amendements je vous remercie
merci chers
collègu monsieur Stéphan demi pour 3
minutes monsieur le Président madames et
madames et messieurs les ministres chers
rapporteurs chers collègues le transport
aérien sort tout juste d'une terrible
crise avec un un retour à la normale du
trafic prévu en 2 24 mais déjà déjà de
nouveaux et et importants défis se
présentent avant cela un mot sur
l'administration responsable du secteur
dont la situation est plus que critique
comme cela a été évoqué tout à l'heure
sa dette a explosé passant de 700
millions d'euros en 2019 à 2,7 milliards
fin 2022 l'administration a certes
annoncé une trajectoire ambitieuse de
désendettement mais parallèlement elle
doit mener d'intens investissements de
modernisation du fait de l'obsolescence
des outils du du contrôle aérien
français espérons donc que ce
désendettement ne se fasse pas au
détriment du rattrapage technologique
dont le contrôle aérien a urgemment
besoin concernant maintenant l'enjeu
crucial de la décarbonation du secteur
il faut créer quasiment exniilo une
filière de carburant aérien
durable messieurs les ministres le plan
annoncé par le président de la
République d'un montant de 200 millions
d'euros permettra tout au plus de
produire une goutte de biocarburant dans
un océan de kérosène il faut être me
semble-t-il beaucoup plus ambitieux en
soutenant la filière et en accompagnant
les compagnies c'est un enjeu de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique j'ai déposé un amendement en
ce sens au nom de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable je me réjouis de
son adoption et j'espère qu'il ne sera
pas torpillé par la grande faucheuse du
493 par ailleurs les premiers éléments
de la future programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie m'inquiètent en effet
l'usage de la biomasse dans le secteur
aérien ne sera développé que je cite
raisonnablement et sous condition
comment prétendre alors vouloir
respecter les nouveaux objectifs
européens fixés dans le règlement refuel
eu aviation si on veut être à la hauteur
des ambitions annoncées encore faut-il
que les décisions le soient également
surtout que le secteur aérien cela été
évoqué tout à l'heure par le rapporteur
spécial à d'autres cailloux dans la
chaussure comme par exemple la nouvelle
les fameuses taxes sur les
infrastructures qui risquent de
l'impacter très durablement il faut
également mesdames mesdames et messieurs
les ministres soutenir la soubriété
énergétique des aéronefs et pour cela
encourager le renouvellement des flottes
j'espère que là aussi l'amendement de la
commission adopté en Science Publique ne
sera pas rayé d'un trait de plume par la
direction du budget je souhaite pour
conclure évoquer l'attaque sur les
nuisans sonores aéroportuaires la tnsa
qui finance vous le savez les travaux
d'un Sonor les Riv des aéroports cette
taxe a vu son rendement fortement
baisser lors de la crise sanitaire je
proposerai donc tout à l'heure d'adopter
un amendement pour compenser cette
baisse proposition formulée par la
commission chaque année depuis 4 ans je
crois le gouvernement ne l'a entendu que
d'une oreille espérons que la deème
oreille frtilla positivement à cette
proposition teintée de bon
sens merci
monsie
merci merci madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable a
émis un avis favorable à l'adoption des
crédits relatifs au transport routiers
de la mission écologie développement et
mobilité durable sous réserve bien sûr
de l'adoption de 14 amendements trois de
ces amendements ont d'ors et déjà été
adopté ce dont je me félicite il portait
respectivement sur la diminution du taux
de TVA 55 sur les transports du
quotidien la généralisation à tout le
territoire de l'expérimentation du prêt
à taux zéro pour l'acquisition d'un
véhicule léger pe peu loin et le
prolongement d'un an de ce dispositif et
enfin l'instauration d'un prêt à taux
zéro pour l'acquisition de véhicules
lourds
popolement je vous présenterai au nom de
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire du développement durable
d'autres amendements an sur les crédits
de la mission que nous examinons
aujourd'hui je souhaiterais aborder deux
points mis en avant dans mon rapport
pour avis premièrement la question du
modèle de financement des autorités
organisatrices de la mobilité qui
doivent répondre à de multiples défis
d'une part elles vont faire face à une
forte hausse de la demande de transport
collectif sous l'effet de la mise en
œuvre rapide des zones à faible émission
de mobilité et de celle des services
express régionaux métropolitains les CME
projet de loi que nous avons voté
récemment elles sont en outre
confrontées à une hausse de leurs
dépenses de fonctionnement du fait de
l'inflation il vont devoir intégrer à
leur équation budgétaire les coûts liés
au renouvellement de leur flotte de
véhicule le PLF pour 2024 envoie un
signal positif en réhaussant le plafond
du versement mobilité le VM à Paris et
dans la petite couronne néanmoins ce
traitement particulier de la région
parisienne interroge au regard des
besoins considérable auxquel font
également face les autres AOM il me
semble donc urgent d'engager une
réflexion sur une évolution du versement
mobilité en prêtant une attention
particulière aux AOM situés en zone peu
dense dont le potentiel fiscal ne permet
pas de lever le versement mobilité
deuxièmement le financement du
verdissement du parc automobile
constitue un autre point d'alerte là
encore un soutien plus volontariste est
nécessaire en faveur des AOM qui font
face à des coûts considérables du fait
des obligations de renouvellement de
leur flotte d'autobus et autocar il faut
en outre redoubler d'effort pour
accompagner les ménages et
professionnels dans le verdissement de
leur véhicules l'annonce du lancement du
leasing social au 1er janvier 2024 est
donc une bonne nouvelle mais on ne peut
que s'alarmer du flou artistique ou
administratif entretenue sur l'enveloppe
budgétaire prévue et sur les modalités
précises de mise en œuvre dans ces
on peut craindre un nouvel ajournement
du dispositif ou tout le moins un
démarrage très timide cela ne serait pas
acceptable compte tenu des besoins et de
l'attente que suscite ce dispositif nous
allons donc y regarder très
particulièrement je vous remercie
beaucoup madame la ministre et Monsieur
le Ministre merci chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Philippe Tabaro
pour 3
[Applaudissements]
minutes
plus monsur le Président c'est encore
moi monsieur le Président madamees et
messieurs les ministres chers
rapporteurs mes chers collègues la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable a
émis un avis favorable sur les crédits
relatifs au transport ferroviaires
fluviaux et maritime pour l'année 2024
si l'effort budgétaire consenti mérite
d'être salué
les transports avec comme fil d'Arian le
ferroviaire ne doivent plus rester àqu
le ferroviaire a longtemps était source
d'instabilité dans l'action du
gouvernement priorité donné au train du
quotidien une année puis celle suivante
à la grande vitesse et l'année d'après
aux petites lignes après des années sans
cap il semble se dessiner en 2024 un
début timide de stabilité je dis bien
timide car nous demeurons
malheureusement dans un léger brouillard
un léger brouillard aussi sur le
financecement du plan de 100 milliards
annoncé par la première ministre que sur
celui des cernes l'ASS d'atant nous vous
donnons rendez-vous en juin 2024 pour
enfin connaître la vraie participation
de l'État à travers une demande de
rapport il faut agir il faut planifier
il faut flécher des ressources pérennes
TVA 55 enveloppe supplémentaire en
faveur de la modernisation soutien au
vagons isolés voilà des mesures que nous
qui nous permettront de sortir notre
réseau de sa paupérisation et de revoir
enfin à la hausse le contrat de
performance entre l'État et réseau pour
le transport fluvial encore trop
sous-exploité nous devons doper ses
capacités en corrélation avec la
cérémonie des Jeux Olympiques et la
reprise des circulation dans les Haut-
de France enfin pour le secteur
fortement concurrentiel qui est le
maritime et le portuaire rendons le
encore plus compétitif et plus vertueux
au niveau
environnemental agir sur les mobilité
s'est proposé une diversité de solutions
dans tous les secteurs telle est
l'ambition portée par notre
commission merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Didier
Mandelli merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur les
ministres
tout d'abord excuser mon collègue
Guillaume chevrolier donc je vais me
faire son son porte-parole pour vous
faire lecture du rapport qu'il a préparé
à votre
intention comme viennent de l'indiquer
les rapporteurs spéciaux la trajectoire
budgétaire en faveur de l'environnement
est plutôt encourageante le doublement
des crédits consacrés à la biodiversité
permettra d'impulser la nouvelle
stratégie nationale pour 2030 qui
espérons-le ne se soldera pas par un
écheac comme les précédentes le
relèvement du plafond mordant des
agences de l'au fait présag une
politique de l'eau mieux outillée pour
relever les nouveaux défis avec les
objectifs de sobriété et de reconquête
de la qualité de la ressource je
n'apprends cependant à personne dans cet
hémicycle que les mesures budgétaires
inscrites dans le PLF ne constituent que
des impulsions et ne garantissent pas à
ell seul le succès des politiques
publiques les enjeux des politiques
environnementales sont colossaux et ne
saurrait être relevé uniquement par des
moyens budgétaires nouveaux aussi
ambitieux soit-il au-delà des moyens la
question de la cohérence des politiques
environnementales se pose avec une acé
grandissante les efforts affichés au
sein de cette mission ne doivent pas
être contrecarré par des mesures aux
effets contraires parfois ce que fait la
main budgétaire de l'État peut-être
neutralisé parce que fait la main
fiscale cet impératif de cohérence doit
désormais irriguer l'ensemble des
politiques publiques sectorielles en
outre en matière de préservation et de
restauration de la biodiversité l'État
n'est qu'un acteur parmi d'autres le
rôle des les collectivités territoriales
doivent être rappelé avec force elles
doivent être mieux associé car ce sont
les véritables moteurs des transitions
l'action locale est déterminante pour la
biodiversité bien plus encore que pour
le climat à titre d'exemple je souhaite
évoquer le pacte en faveur de la ha et
son objectif de restauration de 50000 km
de luné RDV d'ici à 2030 la préservation
et le développement de ces véritables
tours de Babel écologique permettent
d'améliorer les services écosystémiques
rendus par les trames bocagères
séquestration de carbone coup vent
gestion des flus hydriques avantage pour
les animaux également pour les prairies
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'appelle
de mes vœux une stratégie ambitieuse
cohérente et qui associe les
agriculteurs ainsi que les gestionnaires
en valorisant économiquement l'entretien
des je terminerai mon intervention en
évoquant la politique de l'eau au fil
des années la centralité des agences de
l'eau s'est affirmé et leurs
interventions territoriales produisent
de puissants effets leviers le
rehaussement progressif du plafond
mordant des recettes était un prérequis
afin de relever les déficit hydriques
croissants et d'assumer des missions
élargies à la biodiversité sans perdre
de vue l'objectif d'une haute qualité en
quantité plus complexe à atteindre du
fait des pressions qui s'exercent sur la
ressource enfin la réforme des
redevances DEA faire devra faire l'objet
d'une réflexion mieux préparée concertée
avec les acteurs pour favoriser le
consentement à payer d'une ressource
dont on sait désormais qu'elle peut
venir à manquer dans notre pays je vous
remercie au nom Guillaume chevorier
merci Monsieur Fabien
[Applaudissements]
jeun bonjour
monsieur monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre messieurs les
ministres messieurs madames les rapport
mesdames monsieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues le rapport pour avis que
j'ai présenté à la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable porté sur les
crédits relatifs à la transition
énergétique et au climat
ce travail s'est concentré comme à
l'accoutumé sur trois thèmes le
verdissement des finances publiques le
développement des énergies renouvelables
la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments concernant le verdissement des
finances publiques notre Commission a
estimé qu'il était urgent de mieux
outiller et de mieux accompagner les
collectivités territoriales pour faire
face au murs d'investissement vert qui
se présentent devant elle à cet égard si
le budget vert constitue un outil
pertinent pour les élus locaux sa
généralisation voulue par l'Assemblée
nationale pourrait être
contre-productive car prématuré c'est
également l'avis des associations
environnementales que j'ai entendu avec
mes collègue chevrolier et Martin nous
vous proposerons donc un amendement
rendant facultatif pour l'instant
l'élaboration de ce budget vert notre
Commission a également souhaité se
saisir de l'opportunité offerte par cet
examen budgétaire pour prolonger les
efforts initiés par la loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables adopté en 2023 c'est le
sens des amendements que notre
commission a adopté tendant à accélérer
le déploiement des capacités de
production photovoltaïque à renforcer
les moyens en faveur de la chaleur et du
froid renouvela et à faire bénéficier
les territoires des retombées
économiques des projets le Sénat a
retenu certaines de ses propositions
l'extension de l'cooptz à
l'autoconsommation le taux de TVA 55 sur
les réseaux de froid ou encore la
suppression de l'article qui prévoyait
une exonération de taxes foncières sur
les éoliennes sur notre suggestion le
Sénat également accru les recettes
budgétaires de 400 millions d'euros
grâce au relèvement de la du taux de
contribution sur la rente infraarginale
nous vous proposerons de prolonger
aujourd'hui cette dynamique et de
profiter des marges financières ainsi
dégagées par notre amendement sur la
contribution sur la rente inframarginale
en augmentant les moyens du fond chaleur
de 820 millions à 1 milliard d'euros
montant cohérent avec celui proposé par
le récent rapport de la commission
d'enquête sénatoriale sur la rénovation
énergétique nous vous proposerons
également de créer un fond de garantie
doté de 50 millions d'euros géré par
laadem pour encourager la valorisation
de la chaleur fatale nous relayons ainsi
une recommandation faite par le
Secrétariat général à la planification
écologique enfin concernant la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
nous constatons que la hausse annoncée
des crédits découle pour partie d'une
habile distorsion de périmètre ceci
étant dit la refondte de ma prime Renov
constitue un motif de satisfaction mais
des inquiétudes persistent on peut par
exemple crânne que le nombre
accompagnateur Renov disponible sur le
terrain soit insuffisant ce qui pourrait
entraver le déploiement des aides enfin
afin de soutenir plus massivement la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments des
collectivités territoriales nous vous
proposerons un amendement visant à
accroître les moyens du fond vert de 100
millions d'euros sous le bénéfice de
l'adoption de ces amendements nous avons
donné un avis au crédit relatif à la
transition énergétique et au climat
inscrit au projet de loi finance pour
2024 un avis favorable je vous remercie
merci chers collègues Monsieur Pascal
Martin pour 3
minutes monsieur le Président madames et
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues la Commission de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable a émis un avis favorable à
l'adoption des crédits relatifs à la
prévention des risques pour 2024 cont
tenu de la trajectoire d'augmentation
qui est consacrée dans le budget soumis
à l'examen du Sénat je note ainsi avec
satisfaction l'augmentation des crédits
dédiés à la prévention des risques ainsi
que la hausse des effectifs au sein du
pôle ministériel de la transition
écologique après une stabilisation
l'année dernière et une diminution des
années précédentes je souhaite toutefois
appeler votre attention sur un problème
majeur pour les effectifs de ce pôle à
savoir l'attractivité des postes comment
recruter des ingénieurs dans des
secteurs particulièrement compétitifs le
problème est particulièrement marqué par
l'inspection des ICPE dans laquelle le
nombre de vacances est important en
raison notamment desécart de
rémunération en début de carrière un
ingénieur du secteur privé a un salaire
supérieur de 42 % à un inspecteur ICPE à
poste équivalent en fin de carrière cet
écart atteint 220 %. dans le secteur du
nucléaire la SN et l'IRSN rencontrent
les mêmes problèmes d'attractivité la
relance du nucléaire crée une pénu de
compéten dans le secteur rendant le
recrutement d'ingénieurs spécialisés
difficile ainsi en 2023
91 postes sont vacans au sein de l'IRSN
il n'existe pas de réponse facile à ce
problème d'attractivité des pistes de
solutions peuvent être esquissés pour
attirer les ingénieurs en revoyant
notamment le cadre de rémunération le
parcours de carrière de carrière pardon
ou l'offre de formation c'est dans tous
les cas un point d'attention majeur sur
lequel nous devons rester très attentif
je conclurai en vous indiquant que la
Commission a souhaité marquer trois
priorités pour
2024 s'agissant de la prévention des
risques le premier point concerne
l'amélioration des plans de prévention
des risques technologiques dont le bilan
est aujourd'hui mitigé faute de
financement adéquat et par manque
d'information 75 % des logements privés
exposés n'ont fait l'objet d'aucun
travaux de mise en sécurité et seulement
62 % des mesures foncières logement à
savoir expropriation ou ement ont été
réalisés je constate en effet un
résultat hétérogène selon les
territoires qui dépend du volontarisme
des servic déconcentrés de l'État et de
la volonté politique des collectivités
territoriales concerné par ces risques
technologiques je me félicite de
l'adoption en séance publique vendredi
dernier d'un amendement de la commission
relevant le plafond du crédit d'impôt
relatif aux travaux prescrits par un
PPRT qui renforce ce dispositif le
deuxième point concerne le renforcement
des moyens de l'ASN et de l'IRSN
nécessaire alors que 2024 sera une année
charnière pour la relance du nucléaire
en France dans notre avis sur le projet
de loi installation nucléaire adopté en
janvier dernier en commission nous
avions insisté sur la nécessité que la
relance s'accompagne d'un renforcement
des moyens attribué à la sûreté
nucléaire je défendrai tout à l'heure un
amendement en ce sens enfin nous avons
souhaité marquer l'importance de la
prévention du risque inondation après la
catastrophe météorologique survenue
cette année notamment dans le
département du pcalais c'est le premier
risque naturel auquel la France est
exposée il ne faut pas tergiverser et
tirer toutes les leçons de cette crise
pour mieux prévenir les inondations une
réflexion devra être engagée à laquelle
la Commission prendra toute sa part je
vous remercie merci merci chers collègu
mes chers collègues dans la suite de
notre discussion je vous rappelle que le
temps de parole attribué à chaque groupe
pour chaque unité de discussion comprend
le temps d'intervention générale et
celui de l'explication de vote par
ailleurs le gouvernement dispose au
total de 15 minutes pour intervenir la
parole est à Madame Vanina paroli gagin
pour 5 minutes monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre messieurs les
ministres madamees et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues l'an
dernier le groupe Les Indépendants avait
rappelé les enjeux majeurs que soulève
la mission écologie nous avions été
confrontés à de nombreux événements
climatiques qui ne sont qu'une anème
répétition de ce que nous vivons
désormais annuellement
la fréquence des aléas d'ampleur
s'accélère à tel point que l'on peut se
demander s'il s'agit toujours
d'aléa et que cela justifie la nécessité
d'avoir un budget qui se
verdit la France au côté de ses alliés
européens c'est fixer des objectifs
ambitieux de transition nous pouvons en
être fier une fois que c'est décidé
vient le temps de
l'action notre pays est sur la bonne
voie mais ce ce qu'il faut surtout c'est
se donner les moyens de nos ambitions à
cela je vois deux
impératifs le premier impératif c'est
d'être
organiser cela passe essentiellement par
la cohérence particulièrement dans le
choix que nous faisons c'est-à-dire le
sens que nous donnons à nos politiques
publiques comme nous n'opposons pas
écologie et économie nous devons faire
converger nos stratégies cela suppose de
l'engagement à ce titre je tiens à
saluer la planification écologique
proposée par le gouvernement notamment
son volet
territorial vous le savez je suis
attaché au fait de donner des marges de
manœuvre suffisantes faisons confiance à
nos élus locaux ils connaissent les
spécificités de leur territoire ainsi
que les enjeux auxquels fait face la
nation ils sont la source des solutions
pragmatiques et donc des solutions
efficaces le deuxième impératif et
l'affectation de moyens conséquents vous
connaissez là aussi mon engagement pour
faire en sorte que les fonds privés
soient également au rendez-vous de nos
transitions je vais poursuivre ce combat
car il faut mobiliser massivement pour
accélérer
significativement je pense par exemple à
l'hydrogène je pense aussi au stockage
je pense au Smart Grid je pense au gaz
renouvelable comme je le disais le
budget de l'État se verdit il est
conséquent je note les efforts
particuliers effectués sur la mission
écologie je les salue j'en profite pour
vous dire
que le groupe Les Indépendants votera
ses crédits avoir les moyens c'est bien
les affecter aux bons endroits au bon
moment et les déployer correctement
c'est encore mieux c'est sur ces points
précis qui sont souvent critiques que
nous serons les plus attentif j'ai
choisi deux secteurs clés où la
décarbonation est
cruciale le premier c'est celui de
l'énergie il est évidemment essentiel à
notre
réindustrialisation nous avons la chance
en France de produire une énergie
bacarbone
je me félicite que les crédits soient
relevés sur le volet prévention des
risques du nucléaire la France est à la
pointe dans ce domaine mais le
dérèglement climatique nous oblige à
aller plus vite encore et plus loin
c'est d'autant plus important alors que
nous relançons cette filière les
investissements seront colossaux ils
devront être extrêmement bien pensés
tout retard supplémentaire sera
effectivement lourd conséquences sur
notre indépendance et pas seulement
énergétique c'est pourquoi je renouvelle
mon soutien
à deux upupr supplémentaires à nonent
sur SC mais aussi à un pôle majeur de
formation sectorielle
dédié les EnR seront également un pilier
fondamental de la décarbonation de la
production d'énergie notamment dans une
logique de circuit court production
consommation je salue la prise de
conscience enfin du fait que nos efforts
financiers doivent se tourner vers des
produits propres et des produits
européens utiliser nos finances pour
alimenter d'autres économies qui ne nous
sont pas favorables n'est pas
souhaitable ni pour l'impôt les impôts
pardon de nos concitoyens ni pour notre
balance commerciale c'est exactement le
même constat dans le secteur des
mobilités décarboner nos modes de
transport constituera un pas vers la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
ici la modernisation et l'innovation
seront les maîtres mot les efforts faits
dans les réseaux notamment ferroviaire
vont dans le bon sens il faut les
accentuer c'est à ce titre que je
soutiens l'amendement sur la hausse des
moyens envers la modernisation du réseau
je trouve aussi que l'appui apporté au
verdissement des flottes d'autobus
relève du bon sens à ce titre je
défendrai monsieur le ministre un
amendement en faveur du rétrofit un bon
moyen de réduire l'impact financier de
cette transition et d'y insuffler de la
circularité enfin je souhaite faire un
point rapide sur le fond vert c'est une
idée excellente je pense qu'il faut une
meilleure mise en œuvre concrète de ces
fonds là encore c'est un outil pertinent
mais l'ingénierie reste nécessaire à sa
meilleure réussite
pour le groupe Les Indépendants la
boussole est simple il faut des moyens
suffisants des moyens bien déployés nous
voterons les crédits de cette mission je
vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-François Longeau de
l'Union centriste pour 4
minutes
bien monsieur le le
président Messieurs les Présidents de la
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances mes dames et messieurs les
rapporteurs de la commission des
finances monsieur le ministre madame la
ministre j'aimerais profiter de cette
tribune pour aborder l'épineuse
problématique du financement de la
transition écologique et de sa
planification rappelons-le le constat
fait par le rapport Pisani ferry mafous
il nous faudra 66 milliards d'euros
d'investissement supplémentairirees
d'ici 2030 pour atteindre nos objectifs
climatiques et énergétiques à cet égard
la hausse de 7 milliards d'euros de
financement favorable à l'environnement
dans ce projet de loi va dans le bon
sens mais les montants mobilisés chaque
année ne font pas tout nous devons aussi
donner donner de la visibilité aux
acteurs pour leur ce besoin de
visibilité seurte au principe
d'annualité budgétaire mais un
changement d'approche pourrait survenir
en 2024
en effet en application de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques le
gouvernement devra remettre au Parlement
une stratégie
pluriannuelle définissant les
financements de la transition écologique
et de la politique énergétique nationale
j'appelle à ce que cette stratégie
identifie les soutiens apportés par
l'État aux collectivités territoriales à
l'origine de 70 % de l'investissement
public dans notre pays selon l'institut
de l'économie pour le climat au moins 12
milliards d'euros d'investissement des
dédiés au climat devront être réalisés
par les collectivités chaque année d'ici
2030 c'est deux fois plus que les
montants actuellement mobilisés il me
semble donc évident que nous ne pourrons
pas atteindre nos objectifs sans
visibilité concernant les financements
de l'État en direction des collectivité
territoriale je l'ai dit nous manquons
aujourd'hui de visibilité concernant le
financement de la transition énergétique
et climatique nous en manquons aussi en
matière de financement de la
préservation et de la restauration de la
biodiversité je salue certes l'effort
louable du gouvernement avec le
doublement des crédits qui lui sont
consacrés les cinq grandes pressions qui
s'exercent sur la biodiversité à
moindrissent les services écosystémiques
rendus par la biodiversité si nous
n'agissons pas de manière résolue les
coûts économiques se chiffreront à
plusieurs points du PIB seuls les
actions réduisant en même temps les
changements d'usage des terres la
surexploitation le changement climatique
les pollutions et les espèces exotiques
envahissantes sont susceptibles de
produire des effets transformateurs
c'est pourquoi le surceaut budgétaire en
faveur de la préservation de la
restauration de la biodiversité
constitue à mes yeux une bonne nouvelle
mais car il y a un mai comme dans toutes
les bonnes histoires je déplore la
présentation tardive de la Stratégie
nationale pour la biodiversité pour 2030
après mou de retard plusieurs
alternoimement a repoports elle n'a été
présentée que la semaine dernière alors
que les rapporteurs spéciaux et les
rapporteurs pour avis avaient déjà
procédé à leurs auditions et établi
leurs rapports une fois de plus l'examen
parlementaire s'appuie sur des données
parcellaires des peut-être et je vous
assure que je regrette que les
rapporteurs n'ai pas pu analyser la
cohérence des mesures et des actions en
faveur d'une stratégie stratégie aussi
fondamentale dans le cadre des leur
travaux préparatoires en somme nous
pouvons et nous devons encore faire
mieux en matière de planification
budgétaire de la transition écologique
il en va de notre capacité à à projeter
réellement notre pays dans le 21e siècle
je tiens avant de terminer mon propos à
remercier l'ensemble des rapporteurs de
la commission d'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
pour le travail réalisé je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jacques fernck du groupe écologiste
solidairire et territoire pour 5
minutes merci monsieur le Président
madames et Messieurs les
ministres mesdames et monsieurs le
rapporteur mes chers collègues après une
nouvelle année de record de température
et de catastrophe climatique qui nous
obligeront d'ailleurs à reprendre nos
financements pour y répondre alors que
la COP 28 est tenue de reprendre la main
on sait à présent qu'il s'agit de se
préparer à une augmentation des
températures en France d'ici à 2100 qui
sera plutôt autour de 35 4 degr le
rapport Pisani ferie mafous pointe
l'ampleur des investissements pour la
transition écologique c'est donc en
fonction de sa concordance avec ces
enjeux qu'il s'agit d'apprécier le
budget de la mission écologie hormis le
reflux des mesures de soutien au
consommateurs d'énergie nettement moin
moins coûteuse que l'an dernier les
programmes de cette mission sont
globalement à la hausse mais une hausse
inférieure à l'inflation le fond vert
connaît une progression significative
réponse au nombre considérable de
dossier déposés en 2023 qui n'ont pas pu
être financé ce fond n'est pas comme
promis à la main des collectivités pour
remédier à cette faiblesse d'une
animation territoriale pourtant
indispensable pour accélérer en
efficacité mon groupe propose de
basculer 200 millions du fond vers
l'ingénierie et la mise en place des
pcaet pour ce qui est des effectifs du
ministère ils augmenteront augmentation
mesuré à mettre en perspective d'une
trajectoire de plus de 20 ans de
réduction drastique pour l'ofb mobiliser
sur la biodiversité les airs protégés et
le plan haut l'augmentation des
effectifs est clairement insuffisante de
même l'Institut national deinformation
géographique qui voit son plafond
diminuer ne peut être ainsi laissé pour
compte après les mégafeux de l'été 2022
l'inventaire de l'hygiène est d'autant
plus précieux pour suivre les effets du
changement climatique sur les écosystème
les défis climatiques énergétiques mais
aussi ceux du pouvoir d'achat et de la
santé mettent au rang des urgences le
traitement des 25 millions de passoirs
thermiques la hausse d'1,6 milliard du
budget de ma prime renove est donc
bienvenue
même si une part est un peu en
trompeleuil il faut déplorer le gros
milliard non consommé en 2023 et annulé
déplorer aussi les restes à charge pour
les ménages pour les plus modestes
d'entre eux de l'ordre de 45 %. le
rapport de notre commission d'enquête a
bien mis en lumière les
dysfonctionnements de ma primer neuve la
nécessité de sortir de l'instabilité de
la confusion pour les usagers face à la
complexité de la constitution des
dossiers il s'agit certes d'abonder
encore les moyens nous aurons un
amendement pour cela mais aussi
d'assurer les conditions de leur
consommation mon groupe propose donc de
garantir la stabilité de ces aides des
des mobilité de ces aides en insérant
cette stratégie et son volume financier
dans une programmation pluriannuelle la
sous-exécution des crédits maprime Renov
est symptomatique d'un dispositif qui
s'essouffle dans sa montée en puissance
qui a besoin de clarté d'animation
territoriale aussi de visibilité
budgétaire avec ce PLF l'augment
l'effort budgétaire pour les transports
continue son augmentation cette hausse
des crédits ne décline pas pour autant
de façon lisible l'engagement dans le
scénario de planification écologique
qu'on nous promet certes il y a des
signaux la réduction de moitié de
l'enveloppe destinée aux routiers dans
les CP la part majeure de 8 milliards
sur les 15 au mobilité durable train
fluvial vélo transport urbain pour
autant ce PLF n'est pas le premier acte
qui l'aurait dû être de l'avancée dans
la planification écologique monsieur le
ministre des Transports vous nous dites
qu'à l'avenir il y aura beaucoup moins
de projets routiers mais la 69 n'est pas
remise en cause et si je regarde bien
ligne par ligne je ne parle pas des CP
qui reste de l'hypothèse tout ce qui
concerne le routier garde son importance
voire augmente pas de net changement
pour le rail chantier principal de la
planification écologique nous n'avons
pas le début construit des éléments
tangibles basculant dans ce plan de 100
milliards d'ici 2040 en février la
première ministre nous annonçait
pourtant que ce plan d'avenir
opérationnel serait construit d'ici
l'été l'été est passé et manifestement
le gouvernement n'y est pas encore les
300 millions supplémentaires pour la
régénération modernisation viendront
exclusivement du fond de concours du
groupe SNCF autant de moins pour les
trains de nuit qui ont besoin de RAM de
qualité pour réussir comme en Autriche
c'est en plus la possibilité de réduire
le coût des billets qu'on compromet
ainsi l'essort du fret ferroviaire est
aussi en difficulté frite fragilisé à
présent par la disc continuité imposée à
Fret SNCF qui sera dépeessé au regard de
la planification écologique à engager
n'est-ce pas en fait plutôt un budget
d'attente en manque d'arbitrage
déterminant nécessaire à une loi de
programmation qui réponde aux besoins
des AOM pour leurs service express
régionaux métropolitains qui fasse
avancer la question du vm qui débloque
le frein des péages ferroviaires qui
actionne le pollueur payeur pour le
kérosène ou la contribution poids lourd
qui mobilise effectivement les crédits
issus des enchères des quôtes à carbone
qui atteignent à terme les 5 milliards
par an pour régénérer et moderniser le
réseau vous l'aurez compris si ce PLF
améliore les perspectives pour cette
mission il n'est cependant pas le
tournement budgétaire décisif en faveur
de l'écologie auquel nous
aspirons
merci la parole est à Madame marieclaude
varayas pour 5 minutes du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
kanaki
monsieur le Président madamees et
messieurs les ministres Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues les sécheresses incendies
disparition d'espèces canicules et
tempêtes se succèdent à un rythme de
plus en plus violent et fréquent chaque
degré supplémentaire devra réduire
devrait réduire de 20 % les ressources
en eau à l'heure de la COP 28 les
efforts des état pour limiter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sont
très insuffisants selon l'ONU aucun pays
du G20 ne réduit ses émissions un rythme
conforme à ses objectifs les 10
milliards d'euros annoncés par le
gouvernement dont 7 milliards dans le
budget 2024 sont certes un effort
significatif mais loin des 30 milliards
d'investissements par an nécessaires
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone
chiffrée dans le rapport
pisanifée par ailleurs le bilan nous
interpelle avec une baisse de 13,6
milliards d'euros d'autorisation
d'engagement soit plus de 35 % et une
baisse de près de 15 milliards soit plus
de 40 % sur les crédits de paiement ces
économies qui résultent des baisses
appliquées entre autres sur l'échec
énergie remettent en cause la protection
de nos concitoyens qui subissent de
plein fouet la hausse des prix de
l'énergie la rénovation thermique est un
des principaux remparts contre
l'explosion des prix de l'énergie et un
levier de la transition écologique la
précarité énergétique qui concerne 12
milliards 12 millions de ménage est une
priorité tant elle agit sur le climat la
santé et le pouvoir d'achat des plus mod
65000 rénovations performantes ont été
financées par l'an en 2022 et 90000 sont
escompté pour 2023 nous sommes loin
encore des 200000 rénovations avancées
par la première ministre pour 2024 à la
fin du 1ier trimestre 2023 Lana recensé
moins de 10000 rénovations globales et
la la massification dans la mise en
œuvre de ma prime renove mérite une
vigilance accrue le développement du
dispositif au travers d'une procédure
dématérialisée complexe a multiplié les
opérateurs et nombre de nos concitoyens
ont subi des escroqueries par le biais
de démarcheurs frauduleux pour mener à
bien ces missions l'ANA doit disposer de
moyens supplémentaires tant dans ses
missions de contrôle que de liquidation
des aide en effet sur le terrain les
retards de paiement peuvent placer les
artisans dans une situation économique
difficile des crédits à la hausse pour
les infrastructures c'est vrai dans ce
budget le transport ferroviaire
enregistre une augmentation de 260
million d'euros par rapport à 2023 pour
atteindre près de 3 milliards néanmoins
si l'on considère l'objectif affiché de
100 milliards d'euros d'ici 2040 c'est
bien 6 milliards annuels qui seraiit
nécessaire pour mettre en œuvre une
ambitieuse feuille de route les services
express réseau métropolitain qui vont
mobiliser 40 milliards d'euros le frait
ferroviaire et le transport de voyageurs
qui doivent doubler d'ici 2030 le budget
indispensable à SSF réseau pour les
travaux de régénération des rails
aiguillages et caténire je note avec
satisfaction les efforts financiers
déployés sur les lignes inter cité
particulièrement sur la ligne Paris
Orléan limoch Toulouse la ligne polte
qu'il serait bien heureux monsieur le
ministre de parfire en procédant à
l'électrification de la ligne périg
limoge et périg coutra qui figure au CP
nouvelle aquitain depuis 2015 la gestion
de l'eau reste aussi un sujet majeur et
les différents travaux menés au Sénat
sur le sujet sont révélateur de la
nécessité de préserver la quantité et la
qualité de l'eau afin d'assurer la
disponib la disponibilité de l'eau douce
pour la population si le plan haut
prévoit une augmentation du budget des
agences de l'eau de 475 millions par an
il est urgent d'agir en supprimant le
plafond mordant pour augmenter
significativement les moyens financiers
nécessaires notamment à la rénovation
des réseaux lorsqueon sait qu'un lre
d'eau sur 5 part dans les fuites les
fonds d'accélération de la transition
écologique le fond vert porté à 2,5
milliards d'euros est une bonne chose
mais son augmentation est encore trop
timide pour affronter le défi de la
rénovation des bâtiments publics qui
représentent 81 % de la consommation
énergétique des communes cette situation
est d'ailleurs à mettre en relation avec
la nonindexation de la DGF sur
l'inflation qui de notre point de vue
constitue un contresignal inquiétant au
moment où précisément la transition
écologique induit des investissements
publics conséquents pour les
collectivités le virage écologique
écologique et social que nous devons
prendre nécessite des investissements
massifs pour respecter les accords de
Paris la réussite de la bifurcation
écologique est conditionnée par un
changement de logique économique qui
doit s'appuyer sur le développement des
services publics en capacité de répondre
aux enjeux sociaux humains écologiques
pour ne laisser personne au bord de la
route et dans des domaines aussi
essentiels que l'énergie la mobilité et
la l'accès à l'alimentation en l'état
nous ne voterons pas les crédits de
cette mission qui s'inscrivent de sur
croix dans un budget de nouveau frappé
par le chut du 493 je vous remercie
merci merci mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
14h30 pour la suite de l'examen de la
mission écologie développement et
mobilité durable la séance est
suspendue